als nächster versuch habe ich einen tun
willst hatte frage wann heute abend
meine damen und herren bereitete
eingeblendet jude und ich haben uns
immer wieder einen schönen tag
[Musik]
jugendliche haben uns hier mal wieder
versammelt weil wir wieder mal eine
glücksrad challenge machen will be great
video
ich freue mich nun doch nicht auch schon
mal auf meine kanal einem glücksrad
channel hochgeladen
wo wir auf diesen einzelnen stripes hier
komische aufgaben hatten die wir machen
mussten
wird das heutige video hat uns
allerdings gedacht dass wir das ganze
nichts mit irgendwelchen komischen
challenges beziehungsweise aufgaben
machen die person machen muss dem
entsprechen was er halte reden was er
bekommen sondern wir werden das mit
unangenehmen fragen machen dadurch nehme
ich auch in seiner abstimmung ihr habt
gesagt wir sollen das mit unangenehmen
fragen machen deswegen will ich sagen
wir stecken mehr anfangen muss
[Applaus]
judes erst das schreiben und wir haben
kannst du rückstand noch ein bisschen
mehr ich kann nicht wissen wenn ich will
nur mit kurse dann ruhig etwas mehr
figur auf dusche kate kommst du wartest
du in die dusche piss christ kann leider
nicht wissen
ich weiß nicht wie das geht ich habe
keine ahnung ob es wirklich so kommt
jetzt auf jeden fall meine damen und
gerne 2 jährigen pellet video sein wenn
ihr das mal wieder freut das wirklich
vielleicht hälfte gute aufgaben du bist
schon wieder so müde weil es immer
wieder so ein gebäude das er hälfte gute
aufgaben und hälfte unangenehme aufgaben
also zählt das machen sondern dass mike
geschäften kommentare aber ich muss
jetzt erstmal
nein beantworten ob ich lachen oder
rechtsfragen beantworten
das ist meinem auf youtube ist auch
keine so an unangenehme frage aber pro
jahr das sind desto spiel und ich bin
süchtig danach
wir haben das wirklich so ein bisschen
aufgeteilt in guten tag ich mache mit
ihnen oder fragen was ist das dümmste
gerücht was ihr über dich verbreitet
wurde und ihr habt tatsächlich schwanger
doch irgendwie wird immer mein kleid
irgendwie im wind geweht da das gesehen
haben also das dünnste gerüchte bei jude
war dass sie nicht schwanger ist dass
ich schwanger bist du denn schon leider
nicht leider ließ fragen nicht antworten
und freunde war meine größte angst ich
glaube menschen verlieren
ich habe unfassbaren zu spinnen
ich hasse spenden und ich hasse tiere
wenn sie über mir sind wirklich total
bescheuert an aber ich war mal dorthin
und ich fand das mega drive jetzt keinen
sinn gesprochen also schnorcheln
besonders auf jeden fall nicht so
geschwommen und unserem gewarnt und
lager und auf einmal ich bezogen über
meer waren tische und da bin ich meine
art moment ausgesetzt was machst du
jetzt du hässlich sagte erst einmal ins
event ihre größe sind dann sowieso ein
verteilschlüssel das also meine größte
angst das nächste frage beantworten
musste eine eklige angewohnheit
[Musik]
so oder so es denn sein stehst du hinter
dieser theorie habe ich nicht gleich mit
zwei tage halten dann hast du einfach so
über gestimmt ich bin ein krebskranker
die nächste unternehmen oder vielleicht
auch angenehme frage nicht beantworten
muss bleibt was immer kommt das nächste
mal der damen und herren ist wenn eine
sache am partner ändern könntest was
wäre es wenn du nicht immer deine
klamotten dem sprühen würdest dann
müsste ich nicht überleben würde ich
darüber eigentlich ist ein julia alpmann
hey wie gehts also ganz ehrlich ich
glaube nicht an wunder sagte ändern
könnte die änderung muss dass er dieses
juli weniger kennt und nicht so paul es
die ganze zeit ist echt übel wir pennen
weg ist und sieben acht stunden und jude
liegt dann zwischen heute morgen das
erste 38 kommt die post an ich liege im
bett 100 anderen 23 stunden länger
genannt und dann nach dem handy so
gelöst und war wieder da hab ich da
drauf so verlegt und weiter geplant doch
dass wir die sache die ich ein guter
ändern würde wenn ich könnte einfach
dazu so ein bisschen wachsen weil ich
mehr passen wollten schon recht seit
jahren nicht mehr
das sind petitessen eine bühne hat auf
jeden fall die zeit haben immer als
essen ihre bewertung mit sagt nicht
antworten muss habe ich ein tattoo das
interessante frage ich glaube das ist
das was ich mit am meisten gestellt
bekommen tatsächlich neben ob ich schwul
bin
das sind so die zweite frage hast du
willst untertor oder bist du schwul
das sind 3
also erst warum die frage hier direkt zu
beantworten ich habe kein tattoo links
von meinem körper es gibt viele die über
die stadt habe aber noch nie darüber
geredet haben es gibt auch viele die
schon gesagt aber die ist nicht die die
tattoos nicht zeigen das ist aber so ich
hab kein tattoo und ich hätte eigentlich
nicht häufig die lust auf der tour aber
nicht dass es für immer da ist ob juli
natur hat das wissen wir
[Musik]
pinkl daher heute
ihre fläche die nur ein wenig brüder mit
dem 1
und jetzt nächste oder unter der dusche
wenn ich ein t shirt sich einfacher an
als es eigentlich nicht denken mit dem
einsprühen und das noch mal eins ist es
menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßen
doch schon voll auf den du stück ist auf
jeden fall egal wie viele deutsche an
bord mussten wir von der fia
[Musik]
platz hatte da haben uns gedacht was ist
der verbund liste ort leben jemals schon
mal hin gepinkelt als die dusche
das ganze ist glaube ich würde ich schon
mal gegen gestern das kann ich nicht
sagen aber das ist das wo ich schon mal
ein gewisser war toll und ich waren bei
einer freundin carola im bad und mussten
beide wirklich übel dringend auf
toilette und judas auf dem klo und ich
habe sie gewarnt und damit ins
waschbecken gefilmt
und wenn ich mich eigentlich aber das
augenwasser sparen gewesen
wir haben den ball getreten ist wird
gefunden damals noch nicht
was ist deine schlechteste schulnoten
geschrieben hast geht um eine story bis
das ist das war's dann welche schulnote
bei jude law 36 haben bei mir war dass
ich mir sechs uhr zum foto
die kraft hat hab ich schon mal eine
straftat begangen habe ich tatsächlich
ja meine damen und herren das ist auch
etwas europa ich glaube ich doch bei dem
live stream oder einem video und sogar
geredet habe ich habe mal einen plastik
löffel geklaut
im supermarkt im urlaub oder nord es war
übrigens heißt wer hat denn richtig bock
auf
hier ist das schlecht leckermäulchen
statt teller hier ist nicht gesperrt
aber schmeckt übel geil und den kannst
du halt einfach ausdrücken aber wir
hätten dafür wäre schon mehr premium es
gab halt unseren 100 tabak plastiklöffel
und deshalb fünf euro gekostet
dann gegessen als ich den löffel sondern
ich habe tatsächlich angst danach dass
die mich irgendwie gefilmt aber dafür
zurückgebracht und die meisten kein
problem man hat mich aufgebaut
[Musik]
so freue ich mich
du musst ein geheimnis von den
ausbildern die freut sich seit jetzt
eine million euro
was wäre das nicht okay gewesen ich war
es doch genauso wie die ganze zeit geld
oder eben jemand heimlich mussten sich
verletzten inzwischen und hab mich
gesünder ernähren
eine richtige show party letztens als
felix hier war ich ziemlich schokolade
anbieten sie dabei hatte ich als jude
ist eine puppe und schoko nacht wird der
staat wird wir haben wir haben nur noch
diesen monat passiert es extra viel
schneller vorangehen freunde da jetzt
mal muss mir die ganze zeit so
challenges machen falls der video wird
nicht geredet habe ich euch oben noch
mal verlinkt die letzte sagen hier haben
die ich verantworten musste ist mein
erster kuss oder das hat mir gesagt das
war mein erster coup war in der
grundschule auf jeden fall noch das war
in der vierten klasse und das ist
tatsächlich
meinung haben die freundin gewesen wir
waren wieder 87 oder so und das war also
wir sind zusammengekommen irgendwie
tveit übernachten in einem bauernhof bei
werden willst dann haben wir die ganze
hätten nachrichten geschrieben
eigentlich bei schülervz oder irgendwie
oder sagte er und wir waren halt
zusammen gewannen in diesem quartier
wird unser kleiner gag ist das erste das
wir uns wirklich geküsst habe beim kunst
im garten natürlich auch fußball
gespielt
ich wollte schon immer auf jeden fall
dass ich auch noch das rad der zeit der
vierten klasse hat und sie musste auf
die realschule gehen und ich aufs
gymnasium und dann waren wir alle auf
unterschiedlichen schulen bewusst bin
ich wie die pc erstellte durch das
heutige wieder gemeldet meine damen und
herren die letzte glücksrad schelle
tiere dicht gemacht haben haben mega
kraft bei euch an die hat mittlerweile
fast zwei millionen aufrufe schon
innerhalb von einer woche bekommen
deswegen am wir uns gedacht hey das geht
ab
viele leute meinen helm macht es
wirklich mal mit unangenehmen fragen
deswegen habe ich das jetzt gemacht
leute mit wasser wäre es eventuell das
nächste mal machen wieder mit challenges
eventuell auch damit unangenehme fragen
vielleicht mit ein paar guten challenges
paar böse ein paar unangenehme oder
vielleicht etwas komplett anderes
sie uns gerne und in die kommentare das
ist leicht das video gefallen haben und
jetzt wurde sie hierbei
[Musik]